VR headsets aren't all created equally
we here at GameSpot have tested out Alex
on the four biggest VR headsets valve
index HTC vive pro oculus rift and
oculus quest we're gonna break down the
pros and cons of each headset and give
you our recommendation on the best way
to experience half-life Alex
I played the entirety of half-life Alex
on the valve index for review and
everything worked perfectly fine but
that speaks more to having the proper
space and physical setup for the base
station sensors and room for your own
actions the index is arguably the best
most sophisticated headset so far with a
max refresh rate of 144 Hertz and a 130
degree fov the highest of mainstream vr
gaming headsets and its resolution is on
par with the high-end vive pro of course
you need the proper rig to get the most
out of it and my setup with a core i7
7700 K CPU and NVIDIA r-tx 20/80
graphics card was on point
however the headset isn't necessarily
the reason why you'd want to play
half-life Alex on the index
it's the controllers the index
controllers are the closest a pair of VR
controllers come to imitating the feel
of having virtual hands and that's
because they're padded straps
comfortably hug your hands allowing you
to loosen your grip entirely and still
have the controllers in place now the
reason why this matters for half-life
alex is because the game always accounts
for your in-game hands giving them more
agency and a higher level of
interactivity than most VR games objects
doors and some mechanisms react to your
hand motions without having to grip them
simulating the actions of actually
moving these things in real life you'll
be catching items and throwing grenades
a lot in the game as well and it feels
just so right to perform these actions
when you can just let go altogether and
open your hands in these moments v NX
controllers also have pressure-sensitive
sensors on the grip for each finger so
when it comes to grabbing things in the
game you simply close your hand as if
you're really grabbing stuff all the
other VR controllers have a second set
of triggers for your middle fingers that
typically work to grab objects even
something as small as Zen grenades
showcase the importance of pressure
based interactivity these react to how
tightly you grip and activate when
squeezing them and it's nice to give the
middle finger to a dead combine soldier
and have the controller's recognize the
gesture in true form granted the valve
index might be the most expensive vr
gaming set up right now and seemingly
the hardest to find
it's not absolutely necessary to go with
the index if you just want to experience
half-life Alex but I do believe it's the
best option
the HTC vive seems like the next logical
headset of choice as it was co-created
by valve and shares the same ecosystem
as the index I used the vive Pro the
best version of the vibe and the second
best headset on the market in terms of
display my PC uses an RT X 27 d with 16
gigabytes of RAM and an i7 6700 K CPU
and Alex looks and runs great on it I
did run into some issues where the game
starts to drop frames and hitch while
streaming but that is the only technical
hiccup I've had and the rest of the time
has been smooth like with the index you
have the option for both sit down and
room scale the extra freedom to walk
around an environment can add a lot to
your experience and I highly recommend
it if you have the space for it being
able to physically duck and jump is
surprisingly fun and can help make the
game feel even more immersive just make
sure you have someone to watch over you
otherwise you might hit your hands like
I did so oh I just smacked my TV I think
where the vibe falls short is in its
controllers being in one of the first
major VR controllers they feel quite
primitive compared to the competition
lacking the indexes advanced finger
tracking means you use the trigger
buttons to hold objects it actually
works pretty well but it doesn't have
that natural feeling of picking up an
object the way you get with the index
even when compared to the oculus touch
controller is the v controllers have a
more clunky design that causes them to
Clank into each other don't get me wrong
they'll get the job done but it always
feels like you're the younger sibling
that got stuck with the inferior
third-party controller thankfully
because valve worked on both the v and
index you can mix and match the hardware
by using the index controllers with the
v the index controllers work flawlessly
with the vibe and after switching I
couldn't go back if you already own a
vibe I highly recommend picking up the
valve index controllers if you can for a
better Alex experience
the oculus maybe one of the older
headsets on our list but I've got to say
my experience playing half-life Alex on
it has been fantastic
I actually didn't run into many issues
my first few hours playing I only ended
up having to break away so I wouldn't
spend the rest of my day getting lost
exploring every corner of city 17 the
touch controllers are also some of my
favorites for general VR gameplay so I
felt right at home right from the get-go
I was also running this all on a PC
using a 1080 TI 16 gigs of ram and an i7
processor I have to say everything ran
very well
I opened steamvr through the oculus
software just to be safe as I started
Alex up I end up playing for about 30
minutes until I noticed that my height
seems sort of off after playing around
for a bit I found suggestions on the
internet saying that I needed to change
the height adjust option to hybrid after
doing that everything was smooth sailing
I really only had one crash after an
hour and 20 minutes of playing and
nothing really happened after that
after a while I did come to appreciate
just how easy it was to transfer from
standing up playing to sitting down and
playing one thing that really made my
experience great were the old touch
controllers sure the index has full
finger tracking but in my mind I still
have trouble telling myself the flow let
go of the controllers to grab objects in
the game the touch controllers really
only track half of your fingers the
actual act of grabbing is done with the
ring finger alone which never let me
lose my grip this works out well when
throwing things that zombies are combine
soldiers especially since the space that
I play in is really small technically
too small to actually be allowed to play
in all in all I never really had issues
using the old touch controllers
everything from shooting throwing items
into barnacle tentacles and even gravity
gloving ammo across the room to myself
to catch all felt very good I would say
my experience with half-life Alex on my
old oculus setup was overall great
outside of having to adjust the height
setting at the very beginning I never
really ran into any issues I'm also
proud of myself for not hitting any
walls or monitors while playing but I
did get scared by one of our cats
jumping onto my back while avoiding
headcrabs so take that as you will the
other case I can't wait to jump back in
a c-17 as soon as I get the chance
on paper the oculus quest is the most
questionable headset on this list given
you have a VR Eddie PC the only way to
play Alex on a quest is with an oculus
link cable or a lengthy USB C 2 USB 3.0
cable once the headset is connected you
have to enable oculus link and in theory
your PC will take over the processing
power and your quest will essentially
become an oculus rift i have played
roughly six hours of half-life Alex on
my quest with a 1070 TI 16 gigabytes of
RAM and i-5 4690k and a third-party USB
C 2 USB 3.0 cable I ordered off Amazon
the early hours were a rollercoaster
ride and not the good kind most of the
issues I ran into early on were due to
the oculus link software itself which is
still in beta and my PC within the first
15 minutes my headset not the game
crashed four times the game was still
running on my PC but the quest would
lock up navigating the world fel jittery
and if I turn my head too quickly the
image wouldn't always be able to keep up
the headset lock ups continued until I
plugged my quest directly into the
motherboard this solved the headset
crashes but the game was still a bit
jittery especially whenever I first
launched it eventually the performance
would even out but everything still felt
slightly frame II especially in open
areas however now is a good time to
mention that the footage you see here
looked much better in the headset itself
so don't let it turn you off entirely
the other hurdle you will undoubtedly
face with the quest are the controller's
halflife alex was designed with finger
tracking in mind which means your range
of motion is limited with the oculus
touch controllers your pointer fingers
are controlled with the triggers your
thumb closes when it's on the control
stick and the rest of your fingers are
mapped to the hand triggers on the side
this isn't a huge issue once you get the
hang of things but snatching objects
from afar with the gravity gloves can
feel a bit awkward at first since you
need to open your hand in order to
tether to the object that said once the
performance evened out and I got
acclimated to the headset and the oculus
touch controls half life Alex felt
playable sure it isn't as smooth as the
index or vive pro but it will certainly
get the job done if the quest is your
only option we recommend picking up an
official oculus link cable or since it's
near impossible to get the oculus
recommended anchor cable
it's no surprise that the index is the
ideal platform to play Alex on
considering they're both made by valve
but it's also the most expensive and in
short supply at the moment of this video
the vibe is definitely the next best
option it's designed for steamvr which
makes setup with Alex easy and you can
swap out the subpar vive controllers
with the indexes to take advantage of
the finger tracking while you may lose
some of the more advanced features
playing on an oculus you're still gonna
have a good time with Alex
the only headset we have trouble fully
recommending is the oculus quest as the
oculus link software is still in beta
and can have connection issues but if
you already own a quest and are willing
to put up with its shortcomings it's
still completely possible to play Alex
on it we hope this video gave you a
little insight into what half-life alex
is like on every major VR headset if you
want to know what we thought through the
game check out Michael homes review and
thank you for watching
you